hey guys Ryan right here hey guys I go
here we're gonna watch the trailer day
for John wick sorry Sean Reeves don't
make a move
Keanu Reeves and Willem Dafoe one of the
creepiest looking actors ever don't know
what it's about Sally why waste any more
time people say we talk too much in this
intro well then let's get to it
and sometimes we just kill time yeah all
right I guess we'll watch it oh you know
if it's like a warm yeah I think it's an
action movie the ones on rrah there's no
one home like it should be over yeah
that's what his face is designed for
that's right thanks
how much excuse me how much for the car
she's not for sale
live good day sir
I lost everything
ah was a fun gift from my dying wife
Jonathan you got out once you dip so
much as a pinkie back in this pond you
may find something reaching out to pull
you banging it's personal did you get
that car what does it matter it's not
what you did son
it's her II did it to nobody but nobody
is Joe Blake working again no I just
sorted some stuff out uh-huh
ask your crew how many as mad as you
have
myself keep asking your back
yeah I'm thinking back ah
I'm not afraid of John wick
how kids your laundry no one's that good
I thought
hi I love that guys gotta shoes I love
that how are you like my knees like that
they're not really ready for today oh
then you're about to upset a lot of
people it was Samuel true don't you want
to be liked it looks like a bad version
of Drive or something it looks like a
fun action villager yeah but that's like
I don't know
Keanu Reeves looks like he's having a
good time yeah he should know the things
got originally like most of the time is
not a very accurate so like he looks
like he's committed to it and looks like
he's gonna be fun to watch yeah Sally
change your feelings all I'm thinking it
like what I saw bummed if I was like
he's just mad that they redid spider-man
and he wasn't the Green Goblin
but oh like that item there no just I
already don't like the movie cuz they
killed off a dog so you do that and all
the girls are like no it was cool
because it starts off like oh this is
like a dramatic thriller yeah and then
it's like no this is a badass action
flick I like simple revenge stories like
that yeah I think we're [ __ ] cool like
Kill Bill and no bill is so good
it doesn't look the most original but it
looks like it's what it's going for it
looks like they're doing it well it
seems like a fun movie nothing like
monumental bit well all you want is like
cool action that looks a little
different and it looks that's what it
looks like you're giving Jesus anyway
yeah the matrix is one of my favorite
movies of all time so any time I see
kyani back into the action role that is
not that samurai family did 47 Ronin I
think it was called I look horrible no
one watched it I didn't watch it either
yeah but yeah I'm gonna check this movie
out Sally you can stay at home eating
ice cream and gaining weight
I don't gain weight I can as much ice
cream as I wore Oh
all our female subscribers hate you now
what do ya anyway guys if you are new to
the channel so we're talking about the
transition subscribe to the rejection
subscriber salamander Sally
we got channels in case you haven't
noticed what we do
your face like that button click that
button you know doesn't cost anything to
subscribe me you know people need to
sing about that per se it's pretty easy
you know what I am Sally I am sleep
great fans of the show we're talking
about oh my child he's got a jet gonna
be like okay I get it now
thank you I get enough do good it would
do Justin Wingert hey Ryan you should
give me a super dusim duper do some she
she gave me a super duper awesome
spectacular shoutout well you got a
super duper text awesome which is big
dad you that's you're an awesome
shoutout take care now
hey Ryan you should give me a super do
so duper awesome what are you saying
Justin Wingert that's a lot of pressure
dude I don't know what I could do for
you miss your this video we did the
video justin Wingert you have a big
penis don't forget that this makes you
an automatic genius Sally is here so
have no fear asses your boobs new
awesome Shia good even look at each
other we could edit which isn't you we
just never read each other yeah nd David
9 please gonna have a shout-out please
you're amazing please okay uh yeah sure
nd David 9 um what is the nd staff where
you think no no dessert
well I think he you know blew that one
out of the water
please Commission hey yeah
nd David 9 nd standing for Nike new
direction new Direction new direction
that's better
new direction that's who you are it's
the one direction your than your the new
direction that's where you should
advertise yourself as yes
new direction David coz those other guys
suck lay another right now one direction
I don't like them not because everyone
else hates them I just genuinely like
don't like them I see them and I kind of
wish they were dead and you don't want
to feel the same way about the
Kardashians like I do but yeah like
Justin Bieber sure he's annoying but I
don't like give a [ __ ] about Justin
Bieber but One Direction like god I just
hate these guys they they use their
family to get [ __ ] yeah I mean well
wouldn't you I have a girlfriend now
oh that's right I gotta be careful with
what I say in terms of that department
well good but if I was sink nope not
even gonna go down uh-huh
you almost got me almost got me a new
direction
Jordan Crawford do you I sing you a
rapture Jordan and K hey Ryan can i have
a shout out please ELISA is really
really hot yeah and beautiful but mostly
hot Wow Jordan why I was really into
ELISA
why wouldn't you be me I don't know but
for some reason he posted the fact that
ELISA is really hot on three different
reactions and to it then don't have
ELISA okay this is like a message you
want me to give her something dude
you're gonna make her feel like [ __ ] man
she's right god damn it Jordan Jordan
you're being a dick why do you have to
be such a prick
sally has a boyfriend named Nick her
boobies get away